[Music]
seeing the World Cup lifted is
a huge emotion I always cry
now that I do it instead it's
something indescribable even if it's
fantastic
[Music]
and not Milan
Valentina
at the beginning of 1900 we were a small
artisan workshop in Milan founded
from my great-grandfather my grandfather then
took it over to make it become
a large production company in the sixties
then for example he created the
medals for the Rome Olympics then
they succeeded my father in 2010
we created the major
sporting trophies including the World Cup  the Europa
League the Champions League the
intercontinental Open super competition the
Italian Cup the Champions Cup
we created many trophies
he presented some sketches by the
artistic director Silvio Gazzaniga so he
went to Zurich with my dad and they
presented not only the sketches but also
the physical prototype of the Cup
And this, in addition to undoubtedly the
beauty of the project, meant that
we won the competition
polka dots of the
shinery's to make that each piece is
handmade which were the faults are
medals there is nothing made in Serie A
this  it requires
particular skills that cannot be
acquired in schools but only by
working. Then do
the World Cup you have to
follow certain steps which are first the
casting then after a roughing then the
chasing a final cleaning the
gilding and then the assembly with the
part  below which is made up of
malachite and a band where
the winner is written then it is a quite
difficult cup to make because it requires sharpening
the details a lot you need to make
an excellent boxing of the fine essays
really cared for and malachite is a
very  difficult to work on,
building an object with the
world cup on it gives incredible satisfaction
because it is a truly coveted object of the
top and of football. So for us it is a
great honor and we do it with
great passion every time
and to call it a national team that then brings up
in the end this object makes us
full of pride the little girl
got excited because I didn't really understand what it
was in the sense that I saw it anyway
but I knew that her grandfather made it then
I knew that her father made it now that I
make it instead it's something
indescribable even  if it's fantastic,
a fan loves to see his favorite team,
his player lifting an
important trophy, so the fan
still follows everything with passion and
then puts the same passion as the
player into seeing this
Triumph. So also the love for
trophies  it is fundamental
I hope that medal trophies
will exist forever because in any case
they are a recognition and people
always need
recognition
and in human nature and if there is not a
trophy or a medal what can there
be